le zonage chantal mauduit restera fermé
les 4 et 5 décembre prochains à magny
les hameaux les bénévoles ne pourront
pas être dans la tradition apporter du
spectacle et du plaisir en famille et
entre amis
pour cette nouvelle édition du téléthon
ce serait essentiellement de la collecte
on a commencé à faire une activité il ya
quelques semaines en a vendu des huîtres
lors d'une une brocante locale ça a
permis de faire un petit show papa pas
extraordinaire mais un petit chiffre
quand même et le week-end du 4-5 ne
seront sur le pont avec notamment six
points dans la ville où nous ferons des
collectes avec un petit peu d'animation
tout en respectant les gestes par des
animations qui n'existeront pas non plus
du côté de villepreux l'association
aurait dû célébrer ses 25 ans cette
année les bénévoles vise plutôt un
programme numérique
on a pensé à organiser par le biais de
facebook
instagram donc une tombola quand même on
essaye aussi mais je sais pas si ça va
être envisageable mais on essaye de
maintenir le flash mob qui sera fait à
domicile avec l'envoi de vidéos sur
cette musique de jérusalem même sans
week end animé les bénévoles veulent
respecter le thème de l'année trop fort
avec des records à battre en 2019 magny
les hameaux a récolté plus de 27000
euros
gilles preuve plus de 30000 euros